un objetivo claro acabar con la
dependencia de hidrocarburos rusos el
canciller alemán olaf scholz aseguró que
alemania reestructurará su
abastecimiento de gas petróleo y carbón
para generar una independencia en
términos energéticos carnets cosa que
ahora construiremos capacidades de
almacenamiento en la costa norte de
alemania a gran velocidad ampliaremos
las redes que son necesarias para esto
pero organizaremos las estructuras de
importación de carbón petróleo y gas
para que ya no dependemos de las
importaciones rusas a largo plazo
haremos esto con una velocidad sin
precedentes santa que uso indica atún
alemania se ha visto en una encrucijada
desde que comenzó la guerra en ucrania
su alta necesidad de hidrocarburos rusos
fue una de las razones por las que para
muchos shows demoró su decisión en
aplicar sanciones más contundentes antes
del estallido del conflicto alemán ya
dependían 55 por ciento de las
importaciones de gas ruso el país
también importaba un tercio del petróleo
y 45% del carbón que consumía desde
rusia para revertir este panorama el
gobierno alemán presentó una serie de
medidas recogidas en el que denominó
como paquete de pascua que asegura es el
más grande de las últimas dos décadas
de modo que este paquete este llamado el
paquete de paz también puede leerse como
una respuesta cuáles son los intereses
de la política de seguridad alemana a
saber independizarse el primero de las
importaciones rusas de energía fósiles y
luego de las importaciones de energía
fósil en general
una oleada de medidas que llega después
de que el gobierno tomara control de la
filial alemana de la empresa de gas ruso
gazprom
otra de las decisiones más contundentes
desde la cancelación del gasoducto nord
swing 2 que busca enviar gas desde rusia
directamente